[Music]
welcome to the iron Lords podcast
welcome to the Lord's minute our quick
hit video series where we talk about all
the biggest happenings in gaming and
Beyond I'm your host Ty Swinson writer
for Lords of gaming and with me today is
my co-host Lord King
we have finally arrived at the finale of
She-Hulk attorney at law and they pulled
out all the stops of this finale we're
talking about fourth wall breaks
breaking the Disney Plus app on
surfing expectations wherever they could
there was just anything that you can
think happened happened
and I'm gonna kick it off to Lord King
as we left Jennifer Walters in quite a
predicament at the end of the last
episode you see her in jail kicking off
talking with their friends on what she's
gonna do as she is behind bars
oh okay so it starts off and she's down
on the floor she looks like blumsky they
got in a blonski cage and I'm like
buddy and um that answered my question
because you know um my wife had to bend
the knee uh because she wasn't looking
at anybody uh she was looking at us like
you believe this
my wife still doesn't want to blend a
niece she was like no she was looking at
the police anyway
like she's worse than me
um
you know it's so she's on the floor and
her friends is there and she's like I
don't know I gotta get revenge I mean we
gotta find out who these people are so
we can bring them to justice and the
head lawyer
she's like no bruh
this is about you being a monster right
yeah everybody's seen But the hell with
that hold on we moving way too fast oh
that intro Dome oh you're right
no yo for all you fools let's talk about
nah man I don't like that CGI She-Hulk
you see the intro that's what you would
the classic original TV show hope yo her
neck was so big
yeah and then look yeah I'm such a
cornball because it looks so dope to me
like I'm into that cheesy 90s 80s fail
at Vibe felt and they even did it in 4-3
so I mean if you go back and you look at
it it's it's even in 4-3 and it has the
TV grain to it it has that old low res
that that the 480i res to it and I'm
like yo an ad just did the cheese it was
so cheesy it was so good and the girl
painted as the Hulk it was oh my God I I
can watch that intro forever so now we
get to the episode where she's on the
floor and her friends is dead and she's
talking about now she wants revenge and
they had loyal ladies like nah you know
you are a monster at this point in time
and we gotta you know uh work with that
part right there and there's a deal on
the table if you don't do this that in
the third she accepts the deal right off
the bat and they Fast Track uh the whole
life spiraling straight down the tubes
where you know her being She-Hulk was
pretty much everything that propped her
up to get that job so everything pretty
much fell down from there and you know
that uh um people in the neighborhood
talking about they didn't want her there
so you know she had to move back to her
parents and her parents is such a loving
and and and and claustrophobic parents
stifling parents that you know they want
to protect their little baby and um
her room's still the same as she was
when she was in college uh
and it's just uh it's it's nice to see
that she has a base a foundation that
she can fall back on and she falls back
on this Foundation but she got to get
out and only thought process is to get
out and go hang out with Blonsky because
Blonsky gave her that yo you know you
can come over here so she tried to reach
him couldn't reach him try to reach the
Hulk couldn't reach him
but her friends was doing something too
her friends was trying to find out like
who was Intelligentsia like who was
these people
and then and you know she uploaded a
little video with her twerking her
little body her friend did or you know
from college and yeah yeah they fell for
it hookah you know she looked how cute
they're popping it like that
so I'm like these dudes fell for the
hook line the singer gave them an invite
too easy yeah but we understand where
the plot was going because again this is
a Formula that Marvel uses so they get
over there and lo and behold uh you know
the whole intelligence is there
and her friends made it to whatever
cabin it was
oh my God plot twist this is blonsky's
situation and which which sorry to cut
you off I didn't because I was watching
this with my partner I didn't realize
that it was the lodge until we could
fast forward to oh like once he's down
at the lodge I'm like wait a second are
they at the lodge then I noticed in the
background that Namaste the library we
should post in the background I'm like
oh no yes and then blonski comes out
like a rock star and you know um the
sleazy dude the rich sleazy dude was
behind all of it he was Hawking
and I just love how when Jennifer came
in and you know like uh put the cabbage
on a situation
uh she had to break to four four because
it got too cheesy at this point in time
and it was really really uh falling into
the MCU formula and she just said no no
no hold on hold on she breaks the fourth
floor and they try to shut her up uh but
like ending the episode because the Hulk
comes in and him and Abomination starts
fighting and then and Hulk King the the
intelligencia dude takes her blood he he
gives her his whole plan and he turns
into a little Hulk I'm like what the
hell is going on here
I didn't need to see that yeah I was
just like this is
it was just like real dude bro Hulk and
and that's another Hawking to uh Amadeus
chose Hulk which is really funny dude
bro Hulk really funny hair was the same
way I laughed so much but then she
breaks the full form she climbs out the
app to bust into another app to go into
uh uh Marvel Studios and she's walking
along in the lot
and she goes into the the brain thrust
room where they're talking about the
next season so again season two has been
confirmed yep all right and and there's
other things that lead into season two
being confirmed but you know she gets in
there and she they don't want her to go
see fight everybody's talking about
Kevin Kevin Kevin never said fight he's
sorry Kevin yeah I'm like are we
actually gonna get Kevin in the show
exactly so I'm like oh snap to go get
the cap and she gets into the special
room and and it's so beautiful because
it's it's the actual
one of their uh unreal uh engine five
rooms or Unreal Engine four rooms where
they actually do uh shots so a lot of
those shots is done this is That's So
Dope because a lot of the Mandalorian
was shot on those scenes in in that in
that room all right so she's talking to
Kevin and Kevin is the AI that comes
down first I thought it was going to be
Modoc but they didn't it's supposed to
be Kevin but he had on the Kevin feige
baseball cap
before before the bot showed up I
thought it was gonna be more step into
an office it's gonna be the slow turn
from the chair but the bot with the
baseball cap was also great I said it is
dope and she gave his he gave the
reasons why the formula works and she
gave her rebuttal on why the formula
doesn't work and then she gave her
proposal on how it should go and and it
and he he accepted her proposal on how
it should go but she made sure she threw
a dashing Daredevil in there
I thought we were gonna get when he
showed up got more deer down a little in
there and I'll sprinkle that in their
butt she also said we were gonna see the
X-Men that was like I can't talk about
that yet I was like yo she actually said
that she actually said that right there
and I'm like oh my God how far are they
going to go with this and they go and
they and they they go to the uh and then
you know blonzi gets locked up because
blonski wasn't supposed to be
transforming and you know
signed the waiver to get in the the
truck they took him off and you know
they they handcuffed the intelligencia
king Hawk dude they take them out and
you know Daredevils there and you know
they cut to the last scene where she's
with a family and
the Hulk shows up
oh but uh did the Hulk show up by
himself did he have a special Entourage
with him I had to rewind it
because I did not think they weren't
gonna do that and they showed sakar I
mean uh scar
son from sakar
I lost it
I pointed out because I got a statue of
it and I pointed out to my wife I'm like
that's the sun right there right there
and he has the ponytail
and he's behind him he's like yo I'm
speechless this episode
gave so much because I I was really
pissed off when she was walking through
the line I'm like we're going to waste
the episode on this right here we're
gonna really waste the episode on this
and then it gave so much
in in in in in future stuff because she
did allude to the fact that oh she's she
said she couldn't reach the hawk or
whatever oh she said never mind just
save that for that movie for the movies
like uh we don't need to hear that say
that for the movies so that alludes to
the fact that there is confirmation that
there's going to be a Hulk movie about
why he was on sakar what happened when
he left so we're gonna get a chance to
see that
I'm I'm sitting I'm I'm just dumbfounded
in
how much we got from an episode
that didn't really do so much but it
gave so much of a road map to the Future
and then told you it confirmed that
you're gonna get a series uh the second
season of this and she just came into
her own yes right there and she didn't
end the scene with uh She-Hulk she ended
this the the scene
with Jennifer
and her her little lover Daredevil who's
there for a week yeah I I like I like
the whole like um backyard family picnic
going on and that Matt Murdock was there
and because that was more than I was
expecting because I'm like oh this like
that's having like the talk with Jen's
dad and all this and like they're
actually a uh official unofficial couple
right now even though they're you know
working in different areas but obviously
it's a thing that's gonna be ongoing for
a little bit so I'm glad that they're
pursuing that
um and as you said
I liked how this vanilla did something
different in that it focused on as Jen
was talking to Kevin on what was
important and of Jen coming into her own
as she held Again Jennifer Walters
accepting her role as working in both
the courtroom scene and also on the
streets as a superhero and the reporter
even asked her at the very end shot when
she's going in to the Todd case it's
like hey like
all these cases and enemies like are you
gonna fight them
as a superhero or in the courtroom she's
like both
um so it's nice to see her finally
accept that coming into her own and that
the finale didn't do a whole lot of big
stuff for big States or typical Marvel
stuff because it was focusing on
solidifying shoe as a character and
letting you know all those things he may
be missing here gonna be featured down
the line like we're gonna see She Hulk
on the big screen interact with these
other people we're gonna get more
backstory with scar with Hulk I'm gonna
get more interactions with um Daredevil
with the Echo Show
um all these other threads that are
branching out I'm setting up that didn't
need to be crammed here it needed to
focus on storytelling with Jennifer and
her coming of age so that she can
breathe in other mediums yep and I and I
thought they did it so well they pulled
it back they removed all the fluff and
all the you know the stuff that
typically they do like you know you
could say Falcon in the Winter Soldier
build up to a Last Splash at the end
seen you know build up to the Last
Splash at the end scene and this one
wasn't that they gave a lot of reveals a
lot of road map and this within itself
was like uh um what is a d23 because you
pretty much got a slight right right
what's gonna happen and what's going
forward and then we got
how Blonsky just gave itself up so
easily because Hong at then comes and
takes Blanc ski out again I'm glad you
mentioned that because as the end
credits were rolling like okay
has to be an end credit scene for this
last episode and before I cut to a meal
my partner goes
oh wait there is gonna be one we haven't
seen a wall again I'm like oh you think
Wong's gonna be in this episode that pan
is over and I'm like dang long is in
this episode and then Wong did say uh
you know through this Multiverse stuff I
have a lot of stuff that I was doing
yeah
okay so we gotta see okay which show was
along in to see where he's gonna be in
you know so I I we're going to get a lot
of long pulls later
and then yo I'm I'm I'm very pleased
with what they did
um and they let you know you know X-Men
is coming you know so you know be ready
for that and and they're just staying
true to the characters you know so
all the characters that I've seen so far
they've read The Source material they
listen to you guys and they're they're
addressing those issues so I don't think
they're gonna lean heavy heavily into
the same Marvel formula going forward
with a lot of these characters I think
they're gonna you know start uh spicing
it up and changing the direction of
things and I think that it's it was a
great way to end it you know yes
yeah yeah I agree it was it was a type
of Storytelling that's almost well
very appropriate for the fourth wall
breaking an almost meta storytelling of
that you took
um it took a lot of
um backlash and um Angry yelling of
Twitter and you give that a form of
intelligencia and basically Twitter is
intelligence yeah straight up same
arguments when pug was in the lodge
being like like females am I right like
that's how dudes be sounding on the
internet
um
I'm not saying it's because it's a
female I would get the same criticism
should go to the one who who best fits
the job type scenario yeah absolutely
nuts it was funny yeah and and and the
other side of we have Jennifer
presenting the actual constructive
criticism of people feeling like the
flame was getting stale they need to
change it up and um let's focus more on
uh important heartfelt storytelling with
certain characters instead of feeling
the need to fill a type of quota for a
big budget
um franchise or presentation and that
goes to show that even if people don't
think so like MCU Marvel
um these people they are listening um
they are constantly trying to see how to
evolve and get better at their craft
it's just obviously they're not going to
take a lot of the the um unimportant
stuff uh in hand when it comes to the
dude Bros or the yelling into the echo
chamber type beat and what I like is
when uh Kevin said uh transform back to
Jennifer because this is very expensive
this is very expensive and wait till the
camera pans to me then you transform
back because you know Transformations
cost a lot of money yes I was like this
is dope yeah yeah because obviously some
people uh don't understand that yeah um
but overall it was a good ride I
definitely enjoyed the show it was
different it was about the fresh air and
it gave us a lot of insight on what's to
come for the MCU well I'm gonna go watch
that intro again
because it took me right back to my
childhood and that was so dope yep yep
hopefully you all enjoyed it too thank
you so much for joining us to suspend
the Lord's minute we're here every
Monday Wednesday and Friday at Lords of
gaming.net I'm ty Swanson here with Lord
King and this has been the Lord's minute
peace
[Music]